I call him three
three
[Music]
from quavo and offset's emotional
tribute to Patti LaBelle stumbling over
the lyrics
[Music]
some of the biggest names in music hit
the stage at the 2023 BET Awards this is
the moment we are being right now
starting with Lotto
[Applause]
the rapper performed her latest hit put
it on the floor rolling around in a
massive shopping cart through a grocery
store set
yeah last year Lotto took home the award
for best new artist and this year she
won big again this time for best female
hip-hop artist
what is this moment feel like what does
it feel like let's go all the way back
2016 rap game oh my gosh she's so proud
of me right now eight-year-old me 16
year old me and I had a lot of moments
in my career they all proud of me right
now I was Best New Artist last year
and now you know life is crazy I spice
also shut it down performing Munch
Princess Diana and in a mood across a
set made to look like her hometown the
Bronx it was fun you know you thought it
was funny
yeah the rapper spit her lyrics while
sitting on a basketball hoop and while
fans at home couldn't see it she said
they had a little mishap had a little
technical difficulty getting off my hoop
but we ate that serious
and speaking of ice spice koi larae
proved she's a Super Fan Sporting this
black and white two-piece fit featuring
the names of female rappers like I spice
cardi B Doja cat Lotto Missy Elliott and
saweetie just to name a few
coilerae performed her track players
featuring Busta Rhymes who was honored
with a lifetime Achievement Award when
you were up there the emotions really
caught you and poured out I'm looking at
my kids
for the first time all together
at such a prestigious moment in my life
and I'm super grateful because to see
how proud of me they are now and in
another sweet moment Patti LaBelle paid
tribute to Tina Turner who died last
month belting out the late singers hit
the best I was giving it up for Tina
Turner because she's Simply the Best
what if I can't see the words I don't
know
[Music]
Patty couldn't quite remember all of the
lyrics but she told E.T she gave it her
all you heard a little tweet every now
and then out there but I I love her and
I did my best then there's quavo and
offset who came together for their first
public performance in years to honor
their bandmate and relative takeoff who
was fatally shot in November
together the trio formed the group Migos
who split in 2021 but when ET chatted
with the musicians after their surprise
performance they opened up about what
the moment meant to them how do we pull
it together rocket power yeah yeah
rocket power pulled it together